elle la chronique le sport du lundi avec
anthony rech anthony au début tout de
suite par des résultats
oui quelques news premiers résultats du
rugby les joueurs de plaisir se sont
inclinés de peu sur la pelouse de vitry
26 à 20 ils obtiennent tout de même le
point du bonus défensif et restent
quatrièmes de fédérale 3 donc toujours
en course pour les playoffs
en football le championnat de france
féminin division 2 montigny s'est
écroulé complètement face à face à
biesheim défaite cinglante 4 à 2 buts à
0 mais il y monte on reste quand même 8e
de leur poule mais les idées montagne
qui vont devoir se ressaisir pour éviter
d'être en position de relégables assez
rapidement si ça continue comme ça on
continue à parler football on
s'intéresse au sort des différentes
équipes yvelinoise ce week-end coupe de
france et puis coupe gambardella vous
voyez comme promis notre page spéciale
football il y avait la coupe de france
comme vous l'avez signalé et puis la
coupe gambardella c'est la coupe de
france pour les jeunes et les moins de
20 ans et pour en parler sur ce plateau
le capitaine du football olympique de
plaisir kevin maguelone bonsoir à vous
bonsoir
donc vous vous affrontiez ce week end
saint leu donc 4e tour de la coupe
gambardella
malheureusement une petite une petite
défaite 1 but à 0 on va revenir avec
vous tout de suite après un sujet où
nous avons de suivi les deux rencontres
de versailles
en seniors puisqu'il ya aussi allé aussi
de la coupe de france en seniors et de
l'usb en course chez les u19 donc comme
l'équipe du football olympique de
plaisir en coupe gambardella
destins croisés de ces deux clubs récit
tout de suite versailles est lui en
cours avec 90 minutes pour continuer de
rêver du stade de france mais à
montbovon c'est le festival des
occasions manquées
dominateurs dans l'entrejeu dé
versailles et en bleu
n'était ce pas leurs nombreuses
situations à l'image de cette frappe non
cadrée de l'attaquant gregory l'effort
peu avant la demi-heure de jeu à maurice
baquet les joueurs de verrières le
buisson évoluant pourtant deux divisions
au dessus des guyancourt toit sont
dépassés par la vivacité
saint-quentinoise les essonniens qui est
pas réellement le gardien guyancourt toi
excepté sur ce coup de pied arrêté à la
mi temps toujours 0 0 stade mont boron
pendant qu à guyancourt
les u19 prennent le contrôle de la
rencontre grâce à un but d'accès n'diaye
une réalisation logique au vu de la
domination saint-quentinoise au cours de
ce premier acte
l'exploit se dessine au fil des minutes
c'est à versailles que l'expression
match de coupe prend tout son sens pour
autour des vestiaires le fcv continue
d'imposer soirée et comme souvent chez
les bleus le salut passe par grégory
lefort à la 78e minute de jeu le stade
mont boron s'embrase enfin avec cette
reprise de volée du pied droit de toute
beauté
mais à la 85e minute de jeu sur ce coup
de pied arrêté les joueurs de franck
bentolila moins bien physiquement
redescendre brutalement sur terre
direction les prolongations
à guyancourt c'est la délivrance les
saint quentinois se qualifie facilement
pour la finale régionale de gambardella
pendant que les seniors du fcv doivent
s'en remettre à la séance de tirs au but
qui pour l'occasion est un florilège de
tirs non cadrés ou d'un arrêt du gardien
à ce petit jeu les lilas s'en sortent
mieux cruelle issue pour les bleus qui
pourront longtemps regretter leur manque
de réalisme lui en cours doit se sentir
bien seul aujourd'hui mais un isolement
plein de bonheur la coupe gambardella on
en parle à présent sur ce plateau et ça
ne passe pas pur plaisir
oui ça ne passe pas un petit défaite
face à saint leu 1 but à 0 kevin
dominion vous étiez le capitaine du flop
c'est pas une défaite cuisante et puis
vous n'avez pas à rougir de ce résultat
au final non franchement non parce que
nous on savait qu'on n'était pas favori
depuis le début du match et puis on
n'est pas que ça le joue deux divisions
division sud est vous êtes en district
et sont en division supérieure régionale
oui c'est ça et puis bon on savait qu'on
dit pas favorite donc on partait avec
une motivation parce que c'est un grand
bar des lames et puis c'était un match
difficile mais on a bien tenu
franchement et puis on méritait
peut-être de gagner aussi mais bon ça
passe pas et quand ça passe soit ça
passe pas mais franchement on était
content de notre prestation et puis on
pense que ça va nous motiver pour les
reds la saison parce que vous disiez
vous étiez un petit pas vraiment favori
sur cette rencontre pour autant à
l'équipe de plaisir avait réussi un bon
coup en pas le tour précédent mais le
tour d'avant oui le tour avant tout à
fait donc au final vous pouviez espérait
on vous avez suivi lors de cette
préparation pour ce match ce week-end
vous pouviez espérer un meilleur
résultat
waouh n'aurait pu mais bon si vous avez
battu une équipe qui était trois
divisions au-dessus c'est ça une
division de spécialistes mais bon après
la coupe c'est des matches qui sont
différents les équipes s ressemble pas
c'est une autre physionomie on aborde la
semaine de différemment donc c'est
difficile de comparer ces matches là
même les équipes est bon là on avait
réussi un coup et puis on pensait
peut-être que j'allais réussir encore
dimanche mais bon ça ça a été difficile
et puis on a perdu le bronze pas ça a
été un bon bol d'air pour l'équipe par
rapport au championnat
ouais quand même franchement je pense
que oui parce que là
on pense que maintenant avec les
prestations qu'on a fait contre des
équipes qui joue trois divisions ou
voire deux ou trois on pense que là on
peut aborder le championnat d'une autre
manière et puis on est plus motivé
encore que avant ces matches là alors en
championnat il ya deux semaines vous
aviez perdu
voilà une nouvelle défaite le moral et
est quand même là comme vous le disiez
ce s'il est encore là mais c'est les
matches sont différents donc la
gambardella nous c'était du bonus on le
prend comme du bonus on n'a dit que si
on perdait ce n'était pas grave parce
qu'on savait que nous c'est notre
objectif cette année c'est la beauté
donc ces championnats et la cmh lines
ont servi à travailler sur l'esprit de
groupe
le collectif et puis bah là on voit que
ces matches-là au voc et le groupe et
commence à souder vraiment parce que
c'est des matches compliqués et puis
maintenant on voit qu'on peut jouer
clairement la montée cette année avec le
coach et justement le risque pas de
tomber aussi dans la facilité de dire on
est capable de tenir tête à de grosses
équipes alors maintenant le championnat
c'est bon on va le survoler ça va bien
se passer
non parce que ben est par exemple il ya
dimanche dernier on a justement sortir
l'image de national de match ben on a
perdu les quatre 04 06 passage à vide
ouais c'est un petit passage mais voilà
mais là on voit que voilà c'était une
équipe qui joue la montée aussi donc là
on n'a pas n'a pas réussi à faire ce
qu'il fallait mais bon on sait que vous
savez dur mais on pense que nous on a
les armes et puis on va se battre
jusqu'à la fin pour monter parce que ces
objectifs de cette année l'objectif ça
reste la montée 7 en première division
district c1 cette année là le groupe est
assez solide pour ambitionner déjà mai
dernier on est passé juste à côté
depuis bas cette année là avec le
directeur technique le coach et tout la
présidence cette année ses objectifs en
août et pour les u19 merci beaucoup
kevin d'être venu faire un petit
débriefing de cette défaite malgré tout
et on suivra le parcours du fop les
19 en championnat tout au long de la
saison merci beaucoup c'est dans le
football
oui avec un bon aujourd'hui encore voilà
exactement guyancourt le seul rescapé
yvelinois au terme de ce week-end de
coupe de france
les u19 connaîtront leur adversaire
demain soir lors du tirage au sort à 18
heures et puis j'aimerais vous montrer
quelques images alors peut-être que
kevin du club de football olympique
plaisir voire à savoir où ça se trouve
si on peut voir ces images vont entonner
vous avez le droit de jouer aussi
c'est à versailles c'est un bon indice
c'est avenue de paris en fait tout
simplement venue de versailles
et pourquoi et pourquoi cette avenue là
parce que zlatan ibrahimovic devrait
s'installer avec sa famille l'homme aux
1,11 buts par match au psg a enfin
trouvé sa résidence une résidence à sa
démesure on parle de 40000 euros de
loyer mensuel
une chose est sûre en tout cas elle se
rapproche de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
peut être un signe avant que les qatari
ne se décide sur l'implantation du futur
centre d'entraînement
actuellement le dossier de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et le dossier de saint germain
en laye sont à l'étude et puisqu'on
parle de zlatan ibrahimovic
elle ibrahimovic l'attaquant du psg
sachez qu'il est tout simplement nommés
pour le ballon d'or
les dominations les nominations sont
tombées aujourd'hui on retrouve aussi
karim benzema pour côté français et puis
et puis vilain mais moins un certain
lionel messi par exemple martin xavi fc
barcelone et ronaldo aussi on a mon avis
oui mais un pronostic pour le ballon
d'or iniesta je vais jouer les
rabat-joie l'asservir eu la surprise
iniesta ce 7ème à jouer le parisien
yvelinois moi je dirais zlatan
un pronostic pour cette voie là en fera
le point je pense que je pense vie du
footballeur est peut être juste et
pertinent je pense qu'on peut miser
dessus effectivement merci d'être venu
sur le plateau et puis on va changer de
sujet à présent avant de parler de
football américain on parle de trails
oui le trail il y avait de la course à
pied 1 ce week-end avec le très beau
treille de manier la moa vous le
mentionnez en titre à travers la forêt
de porc au real et des plaines autour de
la commune plus de mille concurrents
sané tv ça fait rêver ça fait rêver
c'est travailler mais c'est très
difficile surtout vous le fait les uns
fait moins rêver du rhin ça il faut le
savoir ils ont affronté 800 m de
dénivelé positif donc ça veut dire que
ça monte et ça descend c'est un peu les
montagnes russes sur deux parcours de 14
et 27 km et tft mes filles étaient le
trail c'est souvent le type de course
dont on se souvient pour l'épandre
gravité descendu à la foulée et la
course de magny les hameaux en fait
partie
environ 1000 concurrents ont dû
s'échauffer sur les bosses de la forêt
de chantilly puis traverser les plaines
entourant magny les hameaux pour ensuite
affronter la difficulté rênes de ce
parcours la forêt de port royal avant de
franchir la ligne au stade jacques
anquetil
au total 800 m de dénivelé positif avalé
en moins d'une heure pour le vainqueur
du petit cercle de quatre ans qu'il est
satisfait on c'est un parcours qui monte
et qui descend effectivement c'est du
vrai trail avec en plus des touches
d'humour de par l'organisation on a des
petites pancartes à plusieurs reprises
moins de trente à leur nom c'est une
très belle course et on appris du grand
plaisir sur le tracé version longue de
27 km il aura fallu un peu plus de deux
heures aux vainqueurs
la course a laissé des traces pour son
premier trail en compétition le
triathlète jonathan trio m repart
satisfait mais avec une entorse de la
cheville cassée surpris c'est très
vallonné ses biens techniques
il ya des partis un peu plus roulante
mais dans l'ensemble
quand on regarde deux heures deux points
27 km sur une gagne ça fait très un peu
plus de 13 kilomètres heure c'est
vraiment lent pour une tour sur hot
pursuit se gagnent toujours plus
rapidement et là il y avait beaucoup de
dénivelés moi mon amant garmin j'ai 800
m de dénivelé positif donc ça commence à
faire pas mal et que des montées des
descentes dans une très belle course
moi j'ai pris mon pied tout le monde moi
je suis pas forcément trailer
c'était mon premier travail d'ailleurs
en compétition donc les chemins sont
toujours au chômage jeudi s'est
accidenté il ya des cailloux là avec
l'automne ya les feuilles on voit rien
sur les sentiers
donc effectivement 20e kilomètre moi je
fais partie je suis tombé rien de bien
méchant là je mets de la glace pour 3
quel joueur s'est passé pas si petite
blessure je veux finir la cour d'honneur
chez les femmes c'est fatima salies qui
s'est imposé à la boucle et les 14 km en
une heure et huit minutes